aquí tengo dos vectores dos
dimensionales el vector ay el vector b y
quiero pensar en cómo podemos definir o
cuál sería una manera razonable de
definir la suma entre el vector a y el
vector b entonces algo que tal vez se te
puede ocurrir es observar que son
vectores dos dimensionales entonces
ambos tienen dos componentes cierto
porque no simplemente sumamos componente
a componente correspondiente así que
hagamos eso ok entonces la suma del
vector
además el vector ve a que es igual vamos
a sumar estos dos componentes el 6 más 4
negativo
6 más menos 4 es igual a 2 y ahora las
segundas componentes cuál es su suma
tenemos menos dos más cuatro eso también
es igual a 2 entonces 2 y 2 y como
puedes ver iniciamos con dos vectores de
dos dimensiones sumamos ambos y
obtuvimos otro vector de dos dimensiones
entonces si lo piensas en términos de
espacios con coordenadas reales ambos
pertenecen a r2 entonces lo voy a
escribir para que quede claro
tenemos que el vector y el vector b
pertenecen este símbolo es pertenecen a
r2 es decir a ibex son dos duplas estos
vectores son dos duplas pertenecen a r2
y tal vez tenga más sentido si lo
podemos ver cierto entonces lo que vamos
a hacer es pensar en cómo podemos como
podemos hacer esto visual en un sentido
conceptual pues vamos a tabular los
entonces para visualizarlo tenemos que
el vector a cada componente nos indica
qué longitud se va a mover en cada
dirección la horizontal y la vertical
entonces si ponemos a este vector en el
en el origen aunque no tiene por qué ser
a fuerza en el origen pero facilita la
existencia
entonces nos movemos seis espacios en la
dirección horizontal uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis y dos en la
dirección vertical aquí por lo tanto el
vector el vector hace mira am se mira
algo así bueno exactamente así ahora
otra vez recuerdo que lo que nos importa
aquí es la magnitud y la dirección del
vector entonces la magnitud la
representa que es representada por la
longitud del vector y la dirección en la
dirección en la que apunta la flecha y
también para enfatizar puedo yo dibujar
al vector a cabo o acá o o acá arriba
también la verdad no no importa porque
lo que nos importa es la magnitud y la
dirección cierto y todos estos vectores
representan aa son el mismo vector ahora
ya que estamos en estos rumbos vamos
también a dibujar al rector de qué te
parece entonces el vector b se mueve
cuatro espacios a la izquierda en la
dirección horizontal aquí y cuatro en la
vertical así que el vector b se mira así
es el punto menos 4,4
que inicia en el origen ahora este
vector inicia el origen pero la recuerda
no tiene por qué iniciar en el origen
simplemente es por comodidad entonces
este vector este vector b podría estar
por ejemplo lo voy a copiar y pegar en
otras en otros lugares
entonces el vector b podría estar por
ejemplo aquí o podría estar por acá
porque lo que en realidad importa es su
magnitud y su dirección cierto entonces
todos estos vectores verdes tienen la
misma magnitud la misma longitud y la
misma dirección ahora ya que tenemos a
los vectores a y b
vamos a dibujar su suma entonces lo voy
a hacer en color azul así que la suma
basándonos en esta definición en la
adición de vectores sería 2,2 entonces
estarían iniciando en el origen 2.2 está
aquí así que el vector 2.2 o la suma es
este y porque tiene sentido piensa en
por qué tiene sentido que este vector
más este otro vector verde el vector
rosa más el vector verde sumen al a la
suma hacia el vector
porque tiene sentido bueno una manera de
pensar en ello sería primero a ver este
vector el vector rosa avanza desde el
origen hasta llegar a la punta de la
flecha es cierto entonces qué pasa si le
sumamos el vector verde pensemos en eso
vamos a primero iniciamos en el origen y
después el vector termina justo ahí en
la punta de la flecha ahí es donde vamos
a colocar el inicio del vector verde y
bueno creo que puedes ver aquí que tiene
sentido porque el vector a más el vector
ver ponemos el inicio del vector b en la
punta del vector ar donde primero
iniciamos en el origen y el vector a nos
lleva hasta este punto cierto después
ahí sumamos el sector b y nos lleva a
este punto
entonces relativo al origen cuanto se
cuánto se mueve cuánto cuánto te moviste
los vectores no solamente se aplican al
desplazamiento puedes aplicarlos a
velocidad aceleración una gran cantidad
de aplicaciones tienen pero cuando lo
visualizamos de esta manera puedes ver
que tiene mucho sentido este vector azul
la suma de los dos vectores
es lo que resulta de iniciar en el
origen después te mueves hasta este
punto
y ahí colocas el inicio del vector verde
hasta llegar a la punta del vector azul
el cual representa a más ve pero ahora
tal vez te preguntes lo siguiente
ok aquí tenemos a más ve pero qué
pasaría con ve más a basándonos en la
definición que tenemos de suma de
vectores componente de más componentes
será lo mismo tenemos menos 46 es igual
bueno voy a poner aquí los corchetes
menos 46 es igual a 2 y 4 más menos 2 es
igual a 2 veces que tenemos lo mismo
pero ahora hay que pensar si tendrá
sentido visualmente ajá tendrá sentido
visualmente pensemos porque aquí tenemos
ok vamos a hacer esto vamos a sumar al
vector b más el vector a voy a tomar una
copia del vector b
entonces aquí ya está y voy a colocarlo
en un lugar donde podamos trabajar no
mejor acá donde hay más espacio acá
arriba ok aquí tenemos al vector ve
inicia y termina en la en la flecha y
ahí le vamos a sumar al vector a que
esta es una mejor copia del vector
entonces donde termina el vector ven en
la punta de la flecha ponemos el inicio
del vector y quedaría más o menos por
aquí cierto así que resumen que hicimos
iniciamos en el en este punto del vector
verde y después donde el vector verde
termina ahí colocamos al vector a el
inicio del vector a que termina acá si
conectamos estos dos está que habremos
recorrido esta distancia quienes es el
vector es la suma cierto de masa nos
movimos 2 hacia la
en la dirección horizontal y en la
dirección vertical así que como puedes
ver ya sea que sumamos a más veo de más
a obtenemos lo mismo